Ich möchte etwas mit euch teilen:
Ich habe keine Verbindung
zu meiner Vulva mehr.
Irgendetwas ist blockiert
und der Flow ist nicht mehr da.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist pure Scham.
Seit der Geburt meiner Tochter
fällt es mir extrem schwer,
mich selber anzufassen.
Es braucht extrem viel Überwindung.
Ich finde es so schräg,
so etwas zu machen:
in der Gruppe zu masturbieren.
Du bist eigentlich als ekstatisches,
orgasmisches Wesen geboren.
Ich fühle mich fremd
in meinem eigenen Körper.
Ich weiss nicht mehr so genau,
wie ich mich anfassen soll.
Ich bin mir selber zu intim.
Das stört mich. Das nervt mich.
Ich will das ändern.
Wie finde ich die Verbindung
zwischen mir und meiner Vulva wieder?
Also, ich gehe heute ...
... in ein Orgasmic Yoga für Frauen.
"Orgasmic Yoga
ist eine erotische Verkörperung,
ein sinnliches Erlebnis,
welches dir hilft,
deine erotischen Fähigkeiten
zu entwickeln oder zurückzuerobern."
Schlussendlich ist das Ziel,
dass man sich in diesem Kurs
selber befriedigt.
Man ...
Man muss sich das richtig einreden,
oder?
Es braucht verdammt viel Mut,
so etwas zu machen.
In einer Gruppe
Selbstbefriedigung zu praktizieren,
ist nichts, was man einfach
mal so an einem Montagabend macht.
Der Entscheid fiel mir nicht leicht.
Ich habe viel
zu dem Thema recherchiert,
Bücher gelesen und überlegt,
wie ich das am besten angehen soll,
um die Verbindung zu meiner Vulva
zu verbessern.
Ich habe mich darum bewusst
für etwas Extremes entschieden,
für etwas,
das mich an meine Grenzen bringt
und mich herausfordert:
out of my comfort zone.
Etwas, bei dem es um das eigentliche
Thema geht: Selbstbefriedigung.
"Folgendes zum Kurs mitbringen:
kalt gepresstes Öl -
Kokos, Sesam, Jojoba -,
Gleitmittel für den Intimbereich ..."
Ich muss noch ...
... aus der Küche Kokosöl holen.
Aus der Küche, Ilona.
Es steht auch "Verwöhngegenstände".
Der Womanizer, dieser Vibrator - all
die Gadgets, die ich sonst brauche -
lasse ich zu Hause.
Darum geht es genau.
Ich muss lernen,
mit meinen Händen zu arbeiten
und so die Verbindung zu mir
zu spüren,
und das Ganze nicht
über ein 9V-Gerät herbeizuführen.
Darum gehe ich
ohne Verwöhngegenstände.
Pfff.
Es fühlt sich an,
als wäre es ein erstes Date.
Muss ich sonst noch etwas mitnehmen?
Nein. Mut.
Mut hast du eingepackt?
- Den habe ich dabei.
Der ist wichtig.
Los geht's.
Ich weiss nicht, was mich erwartet.
Ich weiss nur, dass ich am Schluss
in der Gruppe masturbieren werde.
Und das ...
Ich habe im Vorfeld
mit ein paar Freundinnen gesprochen
und ihnen gesagt, was ich mache.
Alle sagten,
dass sie das niemals machen würden.
Das hat mir wieder gezeigt,
dass ich entweder sehr mutig bin,
oder es einfach sehr komisch ist,
was ich gleich mache.
Ich finde es so schräg,
so etwas zu machen:
in der Gruppe zu masturbieren.
Davon habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ich will das erleben.
Natürlich in der Hoffnung ...
... dass es mich mir näherbringt.
Im Gespräch mit anderen Frauen
ist mir aufgefallen,
dass viele
nach der Geburt ihres Kindes
wenig bis keine Lust empfinden.
Bei mir könnte es daran liegen,
dass ich
eine sehr schwierige Geburt hatte,
die mir bis heute sehr nahe geht.
Ah, dort ist es.
Jetzt klopft mein Herz.
Ah, gut.
Huch. Hallo.
- Hoi.
Hoi. Hoi.
Ich bin Susan. Hoi.
Hereinspaziert.
- Danke. Danke.
So.
Aditi
ist sexologische Körpertherapeutin
und bietet seit acht Jahren
Orgasmic Yoga an.
Bevor es losgeht,
haben wir noch kurz Zeit,
über die fehlende Connection
zu meiner Vulva zu sprechen.
Ich fühle mich sonst nicht komplett.
Das ist ein grosser Teil,
der momentan einfach fehlt.
Es ist lustig: Sex mit meinem Mann
ist nicht so ein Problem.
Aber dort liegt der Fokus woanders.
Aber mit mir ...
Das ist für die meisten Menschen
das Schwierigere:
Sex mit sich selbst.
- Eben.
Bei Sex mit dem Partner kannst du
dich durch das Gegenüber ablenken.
Genau. Genau.
- Genau.
Ich kann ja mit mir selber
ein lustvolles Erlebnis haben.
Jetzt machen wir das in der Gruppe.
Was ist der Mehrwert davon?
Das ist einerseits das,
was mich reizt,
aber wahrscheinlich
auch Angst auslöst.
Du wirst viel mehr gehalten.
In einem Raum mit anderen Frauen,
die vielleicht vor derselben
Herausforderung stehen wie du.
Diese Energie gemeinsam zu erleben,
unterstützt einen.
Jede unterstützt praktisch jede
in diesem Moment.
Denn jede springt in dem Moment
praktisch über ihren Schatten.
Aber die anderen Teilnehmerinnen
müssen auch
über ihren Schatten springen.
Mhm.
- Was für Leute kommen hierher?
Sind sie eher jünger oder älter?
Sind sie urban oder ...
Es gibt alles.
18- bis 83-Jährige kommen heute.
83, das ist ...
... so schön. Ja.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Okay.
Ich sehe mir mal den Raum an.
"Ekstase lernen ... Berühren ist
eine Kunst, die wir lernen können."
Orgasmic steht dafür, dass du
bewusste Selbstliebe für dich hast.
Also wirklich ... Keinen Kinofilm
und keine Fantasien im Kopf,
sondern Bewusstsein
in all deinen Berührungen,
in all dem, was du machst.
Yoga ...
... heisst bewusstes Praktizieren.
In dem Sinne,
dass du es regelmässig machst.
Wenn du ein Morgenmensch bist,
mach es zwei-, dreimal pro Woche
für 30 Min. am Morgen.
Ich lade dich ein, eine Hand
auf deine Brustmitte zu legen
und die andere Hand
unterhalb deines Bauchnabels.
Du bist eigentlich als ekstatisches,
orgasmisches Wesen geboren.
Ab jetzt wird nicht mehr gefilmt.
Was ich hier in den nächsten 3 Std.
mit sechs Frauen erlebe,
ist unglaublich schön und powerful,
auch wenn es
mega viel Überwindung brauchte.
Wart ihr nicht nervös?
Ich war extrem nervös. - Nein.
Ich war schon nervös.
Ich dachte: "Ui!"
Und dann war das so normal.
Es war so ...
Es ist so tragend.
Und jetzt ist es so ...
Ich möchte euch umarmen.
Es ist so schön.
Dürfen wir?
- Ja.
Du bist schön.
- Oh. So schön.
Ilona, es ist ...
Es begann
mit einer kurzen Einführung ...
... zur Vagina und Vulva
und unserem Beckenboden.
Dann wurde eigentlich eine Stunde
lang Selbstliebe praktiziert.
Sie hat Musik aufgelegt,
die sich in dieser Stunde
vom Tempo her gesteigert hat.
Es fing langsam an
und man war etwas wohlig dabei.
Und am Schluss lief wirklich
eigentlich harter Techno.
Aber das hat mich ...
... so animiert.
Man ist dabei.
Es geht eigentlich darum ...
Die ganze Energie im Raum ist so,
dass schlussendlich alle Frauen fast
gleichzeitig zum Orgasmus kommen.
Ich glaube, das ist nur möglich,
weil du Frauen um dich herum hast,
die dich tragen.
Du gehst einfach
mit der Energie in diesem Raum mit.
You just let it happen.
Ich frage mich aber ...
... inwiefern mich das
auf meiner Reise weiterbringt,
weil ich diese Selbstliebe
im stillen Kämmerchen mit mir selber
praktizieren können muss.
Ob ich davon zehren und mich davon
nähren kann, wird sich zeigen.
Ilona, du ...
... missed out on something.
Aber Aditi
bietet noch weitere Kurse an.
Jetzt ist fertig. Feierabend.
Feierabend.
Es ist der Tag
nach dem Orgasmic Yoga.
Ich war heute extrem müde.
Emotional und körperlich müde.
Der ganze Tag und Abend gestern ...
... waren sehr anstrengend für mich.
Das war mir gestern,
als ich nach Hause ging,
gar nicht so bewusst.
Erst heute, als ich das Ganze ...
... Revue passieren liess,
realisierte ich,
dass das viel ausgelöst hat,
v.a. der Anfang des Orgasmic Yoga.
Da musste ich mich
plötzlich bewusst streicheln ...
... anfassen ...
Nicht mal sexuell,
sondern einfach mal die Arme
und das Gesicht streicheln.
Das ging mir extrem nahe.
Es fiel mir sehr schwer.
Das war auch der Moment ...
... in dem ich an diesem Abend
in Tränen ausbrach,
weil ich merkte ...
... was für Blockaden
ich eigentlich habe.
Ich erinnere mich daran,
dass ich auf dieser Matte lag
und irgendwann dachte:
"Was mache ich eigentlich hier?"
Irgendwie hatte ich dann doch ...
... den Mut, zu sagen,
dass ich hingehen will.
Ich wollte das auf mich nehmen,
weil ich Veränderung will.
Ich will mich besser kennenlernen.
Ich will mich besser spüren.
Ich will mich vollkommener machen.
Meine Reise geht weiter.
Ich will wissen,
ob es nur mir so geht,
oder ob andere Menschen ein ähnliches
Empfinden mit ihrer Vulva haben.
"Welche Beziehung
hast du mit deiner Vulva?"
Diese Frage stellte ich vor knapp
24 Std. unserer YouTube-Community.
Es kamen 108 Kommentare rein.
"Geht's eigentlich noch?"
"Ich höre immer wieder:
Weiblichkeit hier, Weiblichkeit da."
"Wie geistreich das SRF doch ist."
"Seit einem Jahr bringt SRF nur noch
diese kampffeministischen Themen."
Die Mehrheit
reagierte negativ darauf.
Die Mehrheit sagte, sie wolle nichts
von diesem Thema hören.
Diese feministischen Themen,
diese Genderthemen
gehen ihnen auf den Sack.
Es geht ihnen auf den Sack,
immer von Frauen, Weiblichkeit
und weiblicher Sexualität zu hören.
Ich finde das extrem schockierend.
Dass diese Kommentare
oft von Männern stammen,
erstaunt mich nicht wirklich.
Ich wage zu behaupten,
dass Männer eine andere Beziehung
zu ihrem Penis haben
als Frauen zu ihrer Vulva.
Der Penis wurde noch nie unterdrückt.
Der Penis ist in ganz vielen Kulturen
und Religionen ein Statussymbol.
Er steht für Fruchtbarkeit
und Stärke.
Diese Männer
kennen unsere Problematik ...
... diese Unterdrückung und Scham
nicht,
die mit unserem weiblichen
Geschlechtsorgan einhergeht.
Wie gesagt:
Die Kommentare schockieren zwar,
aber sie machen mich auch unsicher.
Einige Frauen
schrieben in den Kommentaren,
das Thema solle Privatsache bleiben
und müsse
nicht öffentlich gemacht werden.
Das lässt mich nicht kalt.
Plötzlich zweifle ich
an der Relevanz des Themas
und spreche mit Ilona darüber.
Sie begleitet mich hinter der Kamera.
So einen kurzen Moment dachte ich:
"Okay ...
... soll ich die Reise
nur für mich machen?"
Soll ich das öffentlich machen
und zeigen, wie es mir geht und ...
Aber wie du sagst: Es ist wichtig ...
Das war mein Ursprungsgedanke:
Ich möchte anderen Frauen ...
... helfen,
ihnen Mut machen und zeigen,
dass sie nicht ganz alleine sind.
Beim Recherchieren fällt mir auf,
dass nicht nur ich mich
sexuell weiterentwickeln möchte.
Die Nachfrage scheint gross zu sein,
wenn ich mir
die Fülle an Angeboten ansehe:
Instagram-Accounts, Workshops, Thera-
piesessions oder auch Onlinekurse.
Das ist ein Vulva-Shooting.
Sehr künstlerisch in Szene gesetzt.
Vaginal steaming.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich mich darauf einlassen könnte,
breitbeinig auf einen Stuhl zu sitzen
und dann meine Vagina
besteamen zu lassen.
Yoni und Lingam ist z.B. auch ein
Kurs, den ich mal angeschaut habe.
Man ist anscheinend in einem Raum
mit gemischten Geschlechtern,
alle sind nackt
und man fasst sich gegenseitig ...
... an die Yoni und den Lingam.
Nicht alle Angebote sprechen mich an
und auch der Preis
schreckt mich z.T. ab.
Die Angebote sind oft sehr teuer.
Das kann sich wirklich
nicht jede Frau leisten.
Ich habe ein Angebot gefunden,
das mich anspricht.
Dort geht es ums Frausein.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zu Eveline Lutz.
Sie bietet diverse Kurse
für Frauen an,
u.a. ein Yoni-Kuck.
D.h., dass ich wahrscheinlich
mit ihr meine Vulva anschauen werde.
In einem intimen Rahmen -
sie und ich.
Das ist der zweite Versuch ...
... mir selbst näherzukommen.
Weil es eben
keine Gruppenaktivität ist,
erhoffe ich mir ...
... dass es etwas mehr auslöst
oder nachhaltiger ist ...
... als das Orgasmic Yoga.
Hm!
Ah nein, schau.
Hoi, Eveline.
Ich bin noch etwas ...
Ich muss erst reinkommen.
Ja, ja.
- Es ist ...
Ich bin etwas müde.
Es ist schwierig einfach
"okay, let's go" zu machen.
Wir haben Zeit. Du bist
bei einer Entspannungsfachfrau.
Wir entspannen uns.
- Gut.
Du kannst dort nach rechts.
Wow.
- Ich habe den Raum vorbereitet.
Ich habe auch schon geheizt,
das merkst du.
Du sollst gut entspannen können.
Gib mir mal deine Hand!
Du kannst immer Stopp sagen.
Vor dem Yoni-Kuck will Eveline mit
mir noch eine Hypnosesession machen.
Die soll mir helfen,
in mein tiefstes Inneres zu hören.
Das löst viel Schmerz aus,
weil wir u.a. über die Geburt
meiner Tochter sprechen.
Ich brachte sie nicht raus.
Sie mussten sie
mit der Glocke rausziehen.
Es war einfach ...
- Okay.
Und sie war 4,5 kg.
- Mhm.
Aber ich merkte ...
Ich wollte nicht, dass man ...
... einleitet.
- Ja. Dass man sie holt.
Ja.
- Ah, ich weine schon.
Siehst du?
Genau das habe ich gemeint.
Ganz, ganz ...
* Eveline singt eine
träumerisch-melancholische Melodie. *
Erinnerungen kommen zurück.
Das macht mich sehr traurig.
Eveline versucht mit mir herauszu-
finden, woher diese Emotionen kommen.
* Sie singt weiter. *
Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Jawohl.
Was macht dich traurig?
Warum weinst du?
Geh mit dem mit: "Warum weine ich?"
Was macht dich jetzt so traurig?
Ich kann keine Verbindung
zu mir schaffen.
Mhm.
Ich weiss gar nicht ...
... was ich brauche.
- Mhm.
Es macht mich traurig,
dass ich mir total ...
... fremd bin. Das ist das ...
Ich bin mir selber zu intim.
- Mhm.
Das Gespräch dauert über eine Stunde
und nimmt mich emotional sehr mit.
Ich brauche eine kurze Pause.
* Sie atmet tief ein. *
Es ist sehr komisch:
Es hat etwas ganz anderes ausgelöst,
als ich dachte.
Ich merke aber,
dass ich noch das Bedürfnis habe,
weiter in die weibliche Sexualität
einzutauchen ...
... und mich mehr
mit meiner Yoni auseinanderzusetzen.
Merkst du,
dass es mehr Frauen gibt ...
... die mit dieser Problematik -
einer fehlenden Verbindung mit der
eigenen Sexualität - zu dir kommen?
Ja.
Ich habe meine Praxis
seit zehn Jahren.
Ich mache seit fast 15 Jahren
Seminare mit Frauen.
Die letzten zwei, drei Jahre
gab es einen rasanten Anstieg.
Warum könnte das passiert sein?
Eine gute Frage. Die Zeit ist reif.
Warum liegt der Fokus
jetzt mehr darauf?
Dinge wie MeToo,
diese grossen Themen,
brachten sehr viel in Bewegung.
Und die Zeit ist reif dafür -
rein energetisch, sage ich,
was so da ist.
Es werden so viele Tabus gebrochen.
Die Scham darf aufgelöst werden.
Für mich heisst das,
meine Scham zu überwinden
und meine Vulva einfach anzuschauen.
Das ist eigentlich nichts Neues.
Ich habe meine Vulva zu Hause auf dem
Badezimmerboden schon betrachtet.
Aber die Situation hier
ist ganz anders.
Möchtest du jetzt
eine Yoni-Kuck-Session geniessen?
Yes.
- Okay, gut.
Dann kannst du dich aufrichten.
Richte dich so wohlig ein,
dass du deine Yoni sehen kannst.
Mhm.
Du kannst mir sagen,
wie ich stehen soll.
Soll ich auf der Seite stehen,
damit ich deine Yoni nicht sehe
und einfach du
sie betrachten kannst?
Ja. Kannst du auf die Seite?
- Sicher.
Es braucht gerade etwas Überwindung,
wenn ich die Einzige bin ...
... die sich entblösst.
Oh my God. Okay.
Was könnte passieren, Susan?
Was wäre das Schlimmste,
das passieren könnte?
Es ist pure Scham.
- Pure Scham.
Mhm.
- Aber ...
Schäme ich mich vor mir selber?
Was passiert, wenn ich das Tuch hebe
und ... Oh my God.
Ich habe ja
in der Gruppe masturbiert -
bei diesem Orgasmic Yoga.
Das fiel mir
nicht so schwer wie dies.
Ich hole dir eine Yoni-Creme, okay?
- Mhm.
Mhm.
- Dann kannst du deine Yoni ...
... liebevoll eincremen.
Was nehmen wir?
Lavendel. Ist das gut?
Ja.
- Okay.
Gut.
- Langsam. Ganz langsam.
Ich finde das ultraschräg.
- Mhm.
Eveline, ich finde das ultraschräg.
Ich sehe den Mehrwert nicht.
Was bringt mir das?
Meine Erfahrung ist folgende:
Wenn wir Frauen
mal andere Yonis sehen ...
... Yonis von anderen
in einem Kreis,
ist das etwas sehr Heilsames.
Das glaube ich. Aber darum
fühle ich mich nicht so heilsam.
Weil ich allein bin.
- Weil du allein bist.
Würde es dir helfen,
wenn du meine Yoni sehen könntest?
Ja. Vielleicht würde ich mich ...
... aufgefangener fühlen.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wohler fühlen.
- Wohler fühlen.
Anstatt so on display.
- Ja.
Okay.
Du kannst den Spiegel
in die Hand nehmen.
Das ist gut.
Versuch mal,
rein anatomisch zu schauen.
Siehst du deine äusseren Labien?
Eine Hand liegt auf dem Herzen,
die andere ...
... streichelt die Yoni.
Es geht darum,
eine Verbindung aufzubauen.
Die Yoni einfach mal mit
gutem Gewissen berühren zu dürfen.
Das ist nichts Schlimmes,
im Gegenteil.
Das ist etwas Wunderschönes,
das wir haben.
Es ist eigentlich okay.
Es hilft mir, dass du das machst.
Ich sehe deine ...
... Yoni nicht, aber das ist okay.
Ich muss sie nicht sehen.
Dann beenden wir das.
Du darfst dich umziehen.
Ich bin etwas müde.
Aber das letzte Gefühl,
das ich hatte,
als ich von dem Yoni-Kuck
aufgestanden bin, war Versöhnung.
Einen Moment dachte ich:
"Ich will aufhören."
Es war mir einfach nicht wohl.
Als du dann aber meine Situation
mit mir teilen konntest,
ohne uns gegenseitig anzusehen,
gab mir das einfach etwas mehr ...
... Sicherheit.
Es ist ein langer Weg.
Du sagst, er könne auch kurz sein.
Aber ich muss das erst mal erkennen.
Es ist einfach ein Weg.
- Ja.
Wenn man aber bereit ist ...
Eine Person
habe ich bisher nicht erwähnt:
meinen Mann.
Er spielt eine wichtige Rolle
in der Beziehung zu meiner Vulva.
Er hat die Geburt unserer Tochter
miterlebt und gemerkt,
wie ich mich seither verändert habe.
Ich möchte wissen,
wie es ihm dabei geht.
Das ist ungewohnt.
Ich bin etwas nervös,
ehrlich gesagt.
Als du sagtest,
ich solle auch vor die Kamera,
überlegte ich mir das.
Es hat angefangen, mich zu stressen.
Man will zuerst nicht wahrhaben ...
... dass das, was mal gut war,
nicht mehr funktioniert oder reicht.
Aber es ist nicht dein Problem.
- Das weiss ich.
Nein.
- Aber ...
Aber ich weiss,
wie du das selber empfindest.
Du hast das Gefühl ja noch stärker,
weil es ein Teil deines Körpers ist.
Beim Mann ist es halt sehr einfach.
Es ist ...
Man reibt sein Pfeiferchen
wie damals, als man 20 war.
Daran hat sich nichts ...
... verändert.
Und wir haben geboren und ...
Eben, die Geburt ist ja ...
... so etwas Grosses.
Das ist so eine grosse Veränderung
des Körpers,
dann die Umstellung der Familie
zu Hause ...
Der Fokus ist extrem auf dem Kind
und man vergisst dabei sich selber.
Ich muss erst wieder lernen ...
... dass es etwas Schönes ist,
mich anzufassen. Und dass es ...
... auch okay ist, das zu machen.
Irgendwie ...
- Also, okay ...
Ja.
- Vom Schamgefühl her?
Ja. Ich weiss nicht,
woher dieses Schamgefühl kommt.
Hattest du das vor der Geburt nicht?
- Nein.
Dann hat das
mit unserer Tochter zu tun.
Mit der Geburt.
- Ja.
Aber auch zu Hause:
Überall liegen Spielsachen rum,
es ist nicht mehr so erotisch,
es ist ...
Du musst das ausblenden.
Vielleicht kannst du das weniger.
Vielleicht ist es schlecht,
dass ich das nicht sehe.
Nicht schlecht,
aber ich kann das ausblenden.
Das stört mich nicht.
Schaffe ich den Weg zurück?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Es ist super, dass du auf die Reise
gehst, um das zu finden.
Es wurde dir etwas genommen.
Das hat
mit der traumatischen Geburt zu tun.
Du hast mir ja
unsere Tochter geschenkt,
aber du hast selber etwas verloren.
Das ist traurig.
- Oh.
Oh.
- Ja.
Darum musst du kämpfen,
um das zurückzukriegen.
Das muss zurückkommen.
Okay.
Diese Reportage hat mir gezeigt,
was für einen Effekt die traumatische
Geburt meiner Tochter auf mich hatte.
Der Switch von einem Körper,
der funktionieren,
ein Kind ernähren,
austragen und stillen musste -
mit dem Fokus hauptsächlich
auf diesem kleinen Geschöpf -,
zurück zu einem Körper, der sexuelle
Lust empfinden soll oder kann,
fällt mir extrem schwer.
Der Weg zurück
braucht extrem viel Überwindung.
Das geht nicht einfach so.
Diese Reportage hat mich
dazu gezwungen, genauer hinzusehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich den Weg
alleine so gegangen wäre.
Es hat mir etwas gebracht.
Ich kam mir ein Stück näher.
Ich konnte mich meiner Vulva
ein Stück weit annähern.
Aber es reicht noch nicht.
D.h., ich muss
noch viel Arbeit investieren,
bis ich dort bin, wo ich sein möchte.
Was hältst du davon,
dass sich Frauen vermehrt mit
ihrer Vulva auseinandersetzen?
Schreibt mir Kommentare,
stellt mir Fragen und ich
beantworte im Q&A der
nächsten Woche einige davon.
Wenn euch das Thema der
weiblichen Lust und Sexualität interessiert:
Lena von «Unzipped» hat eine
tolle Reportage über die
Orgasmuslücke gemacht.
Und übrigens: Abonniert den Kanal!